This is tomorrow.
Tomorrow very early, someone will go on her first ever run.
Right after, Shelly-Ann will run the 100 in under 10 seconds.
Wow!
By lunchtime, a shoe will grow from a seed.
The WNBA will surpass the NBA in popularity.
This tennis legend will launch her own video game.
Also, tomorrow we will all finally respect athletes' mental health.
A woman will run a marathon on Mars.
Tomorrow we will celebrate new champions.
And once sport is declared a human right, tomorrow will go really crazy.
Marie-Antoinette will score 7 in 7 minutes.
Sky will land a 1620.
Lebron will score 120.
And I don't know what this is but it looks amazing!
Of course, the internet will break!
Well done tomorrow, can't wait to see what's next.